we have had a statement just coming from
Oceania and I do want to read that out
to our viewers as we're looking at the
image of those five men who are on board
the Titan this statement reads as
follows we now believe that our CEO
stopped and rush
zadaud and his son Suleiman died Hamish
Harding and Paul Henry Nigeria have been
sadly lost
the statement goes on to say these men
were true explorers who shared a
distinct Spirit of adventure with a deep
passion for exploring and protecting the
world's oceans our hearts are with these
five souls and every member of their
families during this tragic time we
grieve the loss of life and joy they
brought to everyone they knew
this is an extremely sad time for our
dedicated employees who are exhausted
and grieving deeply over this loss the
entire Ocean Gate family is deeply
grateful for the countless men and women
from multiple organizations of the
International Community who expedited
wide-ranging resources and have worked
so very hard on this mission
we appreciate their commitments to
finding these five explorers and their
days and nights of tireless work in
support of our crew and their families
it then concludes this is a very sad
time for the entire Explorer community
and for each of the family members of
those lost at sea we respectfully ask
that the privacy of these families be
respected during this most painful time
well the statement there from Ocean Gate
Incorporated the owners of the Titan
submersible lost since Sunday afternoon
and now confirmation that the five men
on board
have died